we were going to clean up Gotham fight
for justice
you can help me or not
monsters are coming cleanse this see
blood fire
gasa would tremble before you there's a
new day
hey youtubers is charlie happy monday so
there's a new Gotham trailer so I'm just
going to do a quick breakdown and
there's a couple new characters that I
haven't talked about yet that we know
are coming there's also some very green
stuff that happened this morning that
I'll talk about at the end of this so
they're calling this the monsters
trailer just following up on the theme
that season to a Gotham is going to be
the rise of the villains and I saw a
little bit of confusion after I posted
the last trailer about Jerome Jerome is
the character that they're developing as
their Joker for now now they're not
saying that he's the final version of
the Joker they're just saying that he's
the Joker that they're going with so
whatever your favorite version of The
Joker is whether it be the psychopath
the anarchist the clown we'll probably
get to see another new spin but I'm not
expecting him to wear any face paint
anytime soon if they're going to
ultimately call him the Joker I'd really
like to see them tease that out a little
bit more just to give the actors some
time to develop the character one of the
limitations of TV shows us is that
actors typically don't get a lot of
times to reduce scene so if there's like
a better version of a scene sometimes
they just don't have time to get to it
because they have to film a new episode
every single week Stephen Amell actually
said when he was filming his ninja
turtle says casey jones scenes that like
sometimes they would just invent new
scenes on the spot they'd have really
cool ideas and they would just spend an
extra day or two filming them just
because they thought they'd make the
movie better they can't do that on TV
shows just they don't have the time so
the way around that is is that you just
kind of T's character development out
over a number of episodes instead of
trying to do it all in the single
episode or even a single season for that
matter but we do hear that Bruce Wayne
line about cleaning up the city and the
interesting thing is is the actor that
plays Bruce Wayne said that we will see
a version of Batman this season now
obviously he's speaking in metaphors
like he's not going to be wearing a cape
and cowl but the way I'm choosing to
interpret that is is that we'll see
something closer to world's greatest
detective that version of Batman I'm not
always the biggest fan of child actors
but I feel like if they do something
really crazy with the young Bruce Wayne
character i'd be down for it if they're
gonna let the villains be a lot crazy
this season it just makes sense they're
gonna let the heroes be a lot crazier to
just have some fun with it and actually
if I didn't say it in my last video
Michael Chiklis I don't talked about him
he's gonna be like one of the crazy
crazy heroes think about the way the
christian bale batman treated the Heath
Ledger Joker just like punched the [ __ ]
out of him so you think of him as you
will hehe just going to be kicking the
[ __ ] out of a lot of villains but here a
couple new characters that I'm
not had mentioned before Hugo Strange
who's supposed to show up in season one
I don't know why I guess they just
decided to push him to season two he's a
huge character in the comics he's going
to bring the energy that's gonna turn
Arkham on its head they have silver st.
cloud who's going to be a character that
will interact with the Bruce Wayne
character she's being brought in for his
storyline and she was also part of a
hugo strange story line in the comics so
they might weave that in with Hugo
Strange I think he'll be one of the big
bads of the season and then another step
up the ladder they're bringing in Israel
in case you're not old enough to
remember he was the person who Bruce
Wayne called to take up the mantle of
the bat after bein broke his back in the
comics during nightfall he was so crazy
that Batman had to take it back from him
he's like whoa whoa whoa you are nuts
he's known as the Angel of Death so what
I'm thinking is is they're gonna bring
him in as a hero he'll just he'll cross
the line big time but the problem is is
they say he's going to be a younger
version of the character so he'll
probably be part of the Bruce Wayne
storyline I think my favorite young
character they brought in last season it
didn't end up being a thing but they
brought in Thomas Elliot who's hushed
from the comics they didn't really end
up taking it anywhere but they could
totally revisit that in a future season
just because Batman hutch is one of the
best Batman stories of all time but let
me know which other characters you know
villains or heroes do you want to see in
season two now they have 22 episodes
they're barely done shooting half of the
season so they still have like a lot of
people that they could bring on in the
back half and on to greener pastures so
Marc Guggenheim showrunner from arrow
tease this image for arrow season for
this is just concept art so we have no
idea how they're going to use this it
could just be like a picture in
someone's background but the fact that
it looks like a billboard playing on the
Green Lantern motto just sounds
incendiary like they're trying to light
the internet on fire everyone's always
been wondering if they're going to do
Green Lantern at some point coast city
is just a big place they've been teasing
that's where Oliver and Felicity went at
the end of season 3 there's going to be
something happening there and it might
end up being in the flashbacks the cast
a character that's going to be part of
Oliver's past like a past girlfriend it
sounded like it's going to be Carol
Ferris but the issue is is that Marc
Guggenheim when asked about Green
Lantern's said that because the movies
are going to do so much green lantern
stuff they probably wouldn't be able to
do it on the TV show it could have just
been jerking us around a little bit but
I really do think this
Green Lantern tease is more of a Carol
Ferris tease it just seems like of all
the Green Lantern characters that they
let them use main characters Carol
Ferris would be so much more likely
because they've been teasing Ferris air
on arrow for forever they tease it all
over the place in the flash season one
and red alert five-alarm chili they just
cast Tony Todd as the zoom character for
the flash season 2 now what they did say
is that he's going to be zoomed they
didn't say he's just gonna do the voice
or if he's going to be the guy
underneath the suit when they made the
announcement they said that they were
going for a Darth Vader type theme like
a James Earl Jones type voice and Tony
Todd just has at that booming scary
voice they want it to be a mystery as to
who is underneath the costume like
whenever we first meet Darth Vader we
don't know that he's Anakin Skywalker
that kind of reveal now I'm gonna do
like a whole video about this tomorrow
so be sure to subscribe to get that but
what I think might be going on is that
they're taking the new 52 origin story
of Wally West in the blue flashed the
evil Barry Allen blue flash and
transposing those so maybe zoom in
season two is going to be an evil future
version of Wally West will dig into this
tomorrow but I just I wanted to mention
it because it's such a huge deal and I
know people are wondering about the
arrow and flash trailers those will
either drop this week or they'll drop
the week that the dvds come out the
problem with that is that the dvds don't
come out for like another three weeks
it's like the week or two before arrow
and flash premiere and I don't think
that they would wait that long before
dropping big trailers so I'm expecting
them this week but we'll just have to
wait and see what's going to happen next
is I have a game of Thrones bonus video
and then a Walking Dead QA that I'm
going to post so while you guys wait for
that in case you haven't seen it you can
click here for last night's episode of
fear the walking dead and you can click
here to learn about some of the new
characters coming to the flash season 2
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you